food warehouses burn to the ground in
ukraine
supermarket shelves empty globally
the effect of russia's war in ukraine
isn't just affecting people in the
country but around the world
ukraine and russia between them produce
53 of the world's sunflower oil and
seeds and 27
of its wheat
to put that into perspective if current
supplies of sunflower oil run out
belgium runs out of the ability to make
french fries if wheat supplies run low
lebanon could run out of bread along
with egypt and tunisia and 27 african
countries could face wheat shortages
with russia under tough sanctions and
its food exports severely restricted and
the war also stopping ukrainian exports
businesses are under pressure
there are also crimes against ukrainian
agricultural production
different branches of the production the
biggest challenge that ukrainian
agrarians are facing is to plant the
fields in time 82
500 square kilometers of ukrainian land
is mined this means we need much time
for demining these lands
tas agro is a big agribusiness in
ukraine
its director says it will be affected if
the war doesn't end soon but it is
taking action
the situation with the war is changing
constantly however we created so-called
crisis teams and are preparing actively
for sowing which starts soon
the war has destroyed agribusiness in
the east of ukraine and only fields in
the south and west can be planted
but even then forecasts indicate supply
and labor shortages mean only half of
those fertile fields will be cultivated
in july this wheat field will be ready
for harvest is a crucial part of
ukraine's economy however will they be
able to get this wheat onto a boat and
out to international markets given the
situation
russia has blocked ports on the black
sea and the sea of azov about 13.5
million tons of wheat and 16 million
tons of corn are sitting in the docks
combined with the war and the sanctions
against russia that's led to food prices
rising everywhere and the longer this
conflict goes on the higher they'll get
imran khan al jazeera medve region